if you were both please rise and raise
your right hand I will begin by swearing
you in new faces in the impeachment
inquiry a decorated Army combat veteran
Alexander lindeman and Jennifer Williams
aide to vice president pence both were
listening to Trump's now infamous July
phone call both were alarmed by what
they heard I just noted that the
reference to Biden sounded political to
me it was inappropriate
it was improper for the president to
request him to demand an investigation
into a political opponent opponent
especially a foreign power where there's
at best dubious belief that this would
be a completely impartial investigation
Benjamin is an American citizen who was
born in Ukraine he received a Purple
Heart Medal when he was injured in Iraq
he weathered Republican attempts to
question his loyalty to America when
they asked about offers he'd received to
be Defence Minister for Ukraine I'm an
American I came here when I was toddler
and I immediately dismissed these offers
did not entertain them the Democrats
want to crush any notion that these
career public servants have political
motives colonel Inman would you call
yourself a never Trumper representative
I'd call myself never partisan former
Ukraine envoi kurt volker was the first
public witness called by republicans but
he failed to back their theories about
Joe Biden I think the allegations
against Vice President Biden are
self-serving and not credible well what
goes on in this inquiry will ultimately
be decided by politicians the looming
2020 election makes public opinion on
impeachment crucial inside that room
it's the Democrats aim to convince
America that impeaching the president is
something that simply has to be done but
according to a new poll the majority of
Americans won't change their minds based
on what they hear in that
Democrats are taking some comfort that
so far there's been no major backlash to
their inquiry but no one is under any
illusion that this isn't an intimidating
process not least the witnesses involved
in his opening statement
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh gave this
message to his dad do not worry I will
be fine for talking the truth we're
still in the fact-finding phase of this
inquiry the Democrats want the house to
vote on articles of impeachment before
Christmas they have just weeks to make
their case
bulletproof Amanda Walker Sky News
Washington